The last two decades have marked an era
of ambitious school reform. So, after all
of that work, our America's schools better?
There is some evidence of improvement.
Over much of that period, the
share of students proficient on state
tests rose one to two percent each year.
Meanwhile, graduation rates skyrocketed.
So far, so good. The problem? Test results
and graduation rates are subject to
manipulation by the same state officials
who take credit for the results. In fact,
when compared to national data, it turns
out that state-reported test gains
outpaced nationally-reported gains by 50
to over 100 percent. Meanwhile,
international data show that, between
2000 and 2015, US test scores were stagnant,
as was our international
ranking. In short, the most credible
numbers show the least evidence of
progress. We can debate why we've seen
these disappointing results, but
proposals for 2020 and beyond should
start with an honest reckoning. Do you
think America's schools have gotten
better since the year 2000? Let us know
in our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.